good evening I'm pleased to welcome KB
Joneses this year's George Morris
Woodruff this terms George Morris
Woodruff class of 1857 memorial lecturer
the Woodruff series was established in
2010 by mr. Woodruff's great-grandson
the late H Allen Brooks who has a master
had a Master of Arts in the history of
art from Yale 1955 mr. Brooks was an
eminent historian specializing in the
work of Frank Lloyd Wright and Micawber
yet for most of his long and productive
career Allen Brooks taught at the
University of Toronto his book the
Prairie School Frank Lloyd Wright and
his contemporaries received the Society
of architectural historians Alice Davis
H Kok Award as the best in the field
fourth year that year was 1972 and the
book has been in print ever since after
more books on right Brooks turned his
attention to the Corbusier initially
editing the monumental 32 volumes of his
archive in case you don't know the
Corbusier boat kept every piece of paper
you ever wrote anything on and unlike me
including my tea what is he was told to
buy in the supermarket I'm a and this
was edited on behalf of the Fond osceola
Corbusier and then in 1997 Brooks went
on to publish the book of a corbusier's
formative years the inaugural Woodruff
lecture was delivered in spring 2012 by
E Blau Kurt Forster and Barry bergdoll
have also been Woodruff lecturers
tonight's lecture KB Jones holds The
Bachelor of Arts from st. Olaf's College
and the Master of Architecture from Yale
where she was recognized with the Wendy
Elizabeth planning award given to a
second-year student in the school who
has shown the most promise of
development in the profession she has
not disappointed
she is active in professional practice
she is a highly respected teacher
teacher at Ohio's State's Knowlton
school of architecture as well she has
published extensively in architecture
history principally concentrating on
modern and contemporary architecture in
Italy especially the work of Franco
Albini and franca helg about whom she
speaks tonight it's my pleasure to have
to welcome kV Jones here have her back
at Yale and please join me in a round of
applause as she delivers the lecture
suspending modernity modernity Franco
albini
Kb
thank you very much for such a lovely
and generous introduction it's a real
pleasure for me to be here come on down
as Lane come on there's place for you
girl and it gives me an opportunity to
welcome my wonderful Ohio State students
who are here tonight I thank you for
coming tonight you may see a few things
that you're already familiar with and
I'm also aware of the fact that tonight
there are members of the deans council
who I'd like to welcome I was tipped off
by Terry Duan who texted me her regrets
Terry deserves a shout out because
without her pietà tear and delicious
meals in Milan this work may have never
come to conclusion I certainly want to
express my gratitude to Dean Stern and
recognize that those seats probably that
you're all sitting in are no more
comfortable than when I was sitting in
them thirty years ago so I'll try to
stay on script but in recognizing Dean
Stern how many of you remember the PBS
series pride of place a few years ago I
remembered I'll bet you do a long run
but it was very important for those
young faculty at Ohio State who would
gather every Wednesday evening to watch
Bob and as he shared with us a plethora
of historic and contemporary ideas in
the forms of buildings and their
architects oh that was over 30 years ago
but it's clear that nobody loves
architecture more than Bob Stern and
probably no one has taught more of us
than he has not without strong opinions
but ultimately with an open mind a
generous spirit and a sharp wit so I
thank you for that as well as allowing
me to be here tonight thank you so it's
a pleasure to be able to give the George
Morris Woodruff class of 1857 Memorial
Lecture and now I'll turn our attention
to the work of the Milanese rationalist
Franco albini I'm going to show some
examples of his work with such a long
and prolific career it's difficult I
hope I give a representative sample I'll
be showing what for me are some of the
most important products of a 47-year
career
I'm certainly not alone in having
thought about written about considered
this work one of the things that makes
this work so easy is that everybody
wrote about Franklin Benjamin I wrote a
foodie who knows every local Aragon
Francesco tandoori Francesco del Colle
Ardo benevolent many many more and all
of the best journals featured Albanese
work both in his lifetime and cents
Domus rose Aeneas Tilak has a bailout of
contextual forum so to do this work is
quite a pleasure if one reads Italian
but to my knowledge al beanies work has
not been included in compilations by
modern work by Ken Frampton by Vincent
Scully which means that some of you may
have missed him altogether
in 1956 Denis Scott Brown encountered
Albini at the Siam summer school in
Venice and afterwards she wrote about
the key role that albini played in
continuing the modern project in Italy
after the war albini was certainly keen
to the realities of urban life and to
new found ways to be essentially modern
even while dealing with the facts of
post-war Italy he embraced tradition not
unlike the spirit of TS Eliot or Carlos
cotta and in fact it's this relationship
between modernity and tradition that has
drit continued to build my interest in
Albanese work Sara Williams Gould Hagen
and others have considered a modern
architecture that answers to a situated
modernism my am today is to resituated
beanies contributions among some of the
greatest modern designers and offer a
portrait of this talented architect
while raising some questions questions
about the relationship between influence
versus novelty interrelationships that
occur in the works of some of the
better-known architects and the
characteristics of a potentially an
international modern zeitgeist of which
he was an important part but potentially
has been overlooked
since I first began to present research
about albini in Montreal over a decade
ago I repeatedly found that this
building this department store in Rome
is one of his best recognized buildings
maybe because it's in Rome it may be
because it symbolizes a use of a
familiar building type the Roman Palazzo
as it expresses a new modern
monumentality outside the array lien
wall or for the exoskeletal structural
system that Albini developed and
exploited but if you try to tour around
Italy and look for more of these you
won't find them part of El beanies great
legacy is that none of his buildings
look alike in addition to that many
would argue that al beanies greatest
legacy is in the way he changed the the
way Italians exhibit art especially
historic art and Albania was born the
same year is Giuseppe tehrani
it was tyrannies work that I first went
to see when I travelled through northern
Italy Albini practiced for 30 years
beyond titania he was virtually
contemporary with carlo scarpa and
leucon and at least as important in his
contributions to the design of
contemporary museums all I can figure
out is that albini had a lousy publicist
and so um I've used this modern Palazzo
for the cover image of my book not only
because I took the photo so I don't have
to pay for it but also because the
recognition value is important in the
work of another architect one of current
international stars Renzo Piano probably
you know that Renzo Piano interned with
Franco albini during the years in which
the Rhenish ante department store was
designed he was there for a three-year
period after he dropped out of
architecture school in Florence the
first proposal for the Rhenish empty
stores this image still we see the XSL
little structure but we haven't yet
defined the monumental palazzo facade
and we have parking on the roof and the
familiar surrounding circulation on the
exterior of the building no question
about the fact that the young Renzo
Piano when he worked with Rogers to
build the Pompidou Center in Paris was
significantly influenced by his work
here
and it's worth mentioning that a part of
Albanese identity is as an important
designer and especially if you look for
his work online today you'll find more
work in air furniture than architecture
especially because now like this ad in a
recent New York Times we see that Noll
International is fabricating these works
that one can purchase furniture is
accessible
it's exportable maybe even its desired
because it's nostalgic but it is not
necessarily affordable one has to
believe that this is more likely for a
collector than for everyday use in fact
now Knoll publishes the price as 3700
euro transcends market logic but al
beanies furniture design is perhaps more
important for its cult value than its
market value especially for what it
teaches us about his own design process
this simple chair called Luiza is in the
museum of modern art collection of
design it one for Albini the coveted
compasso daughter award in the 1950s but
although apparently a very simple
artifact it took him really 18 years to
perfect the model that satisfied him and
this is what's important in the design
process of Frank well-being is the
iterative return constantly to resolve a
problem over and over again and finding
in the kernel of the problem a solution
that he could exploit more and more
Albini was erudite he was taciturnity
typifies the well-worn adage of Ernesto
Rogers who described his whole
generation of architects as being
capable of designing everything from the
spoon to the city della cooky Iowa
cheetah not very modest but in fact it
was true and in Albee knees case in
particularly along with his cohorts in
Milan he was responsible for a number of
important urban designs urban designs
for the city of Milan and other cities
when cities were expanding and they
needed the sensitivity of good designers
to be able to understand how to solve
these complex problems
it was al beanies work in this area that
brought him the Commission after the war
and in the 1960s along with Bob Nora de
and franca hal for the line one of the
metropolitan in rome where he used this
idea of ariadne's thread to give meaning
to the city underground my first contact
with the work of Franco a beanie was in
the form of this little building it's
called the Treasury of San Lorenzo it's
located in the city of Genoa it's
literally a crypt
it's underground it's beneath the Duomo
Church and until one's eyes adjust you'd
be hard-pressed to define it as a work
of modern architecture I'll return to
discuss this building later because it
had such an amount influence and is yet
relatively unknown it was built in 1952
or begun in 50 - finished in 56 which
was a real turning point in Albie's
career when he begins to work with the
architect franca hell he had had many
collaborators prior when he teams up
with held the studio name changes and
she works with him for the next 25 years
he also at this time was working with
the Genoese public administrator Katrina
mention Otto and the tiny collection of
very prestigious works of art that
occupied these four rooms were
originally part of an ecclesiastical
collection that was taken over as part
of the public collection of the city
they claimed that this green vessel has
din the first of the four circular rooms
is in fact the Holy Grail
now the Treasury may not be
stylistically characteristic of L
beanies work but really nothing is and
that's the point he was not bound to any
style or Dogma and in spite of virtually
defining the language of Italian
rationalism during his earlier period no
to albini buildings look alike his work
was responsive to the site to program
and yet captured its poetry from a deep
understanding of each and liked the
works of the best phenomenological
architects his spaces are better
experience than photographed subtle
qualities and formal relationships of
the material resolution the design of
lighting these things all must be
perceived in person so well I try to use
diagrams to reveal or clarify his ideas
I still urge you at first opportunity to
have the opportunity to experience these
beautiful artifacts I take for granted
with this sophisticated audience that
there's going to be a high level of
knowledge of the period of Italian
rationalism I won't spend much time
identifying that and in fact I won't
spend a lot of time on the work of
Albini that's typical of this period
this is one example he did many this is
a little propaganda pavilion for the
Italian national insurance agency this
one was in Milan but he built them from
Milan to Bari the buildings are give
good evidence however to where he begins
as an architect and um Albini finishes
his degree at the Polytechnic in Milan
in 1929 the Polytechnic at that time and
for many years after was still a
classical school they didn't have a
modern curriculum he went to work
immediately for Jo punky punky sent him
to Barcelona where he saw the Barcelona
pavilion he would sent him to Paris to
encounter liquid Lussier at that time
period and shortly after he returned in
1930 Albania opened his own studio and
ponte remained a powerful advocate of
albini throughout his career albini
collaborated with a lot of people and
this can make it difficult to parse out
what are his unique contributions but
it's something that I've made an effort
to do in my research so here you get
offense of his love for this lyrical
levity
materials that draw in the daylight and
create create some very suggestive kinds
of interiors
these are explorations that carried out
throughout his career
and he had a particular load for books
you see these artifice is for street
corners temporary book pavilions window
displays bookshelf studies there were
many of them and what a nice store that
remained in the Galleria in Milan for
many years it was torn down just about a
decade ago it was about
valdine en custodia book store this one
is quite lovely it's about a three story
interior space where the books are
actually supported by the walls and the
interior suspended structures where the
shoppers have to move on a series of
mezzanine zand stairs evocative of
historic libraries and yet truly a
modern language at this time when
Italian modernists were exploring all
kinds of uses of new materials the
secret black company produced structural
glass and did everything it could to get
it in the hands of architects an early
exhibition designed by Frank Wahine with
Giovanni Romano is this exhibition of
Venetian glassware held in Sun glass
shelving it would certainly be desirable
to see this image in color if any of you
saw the Metropolitan Scarpa glass show
last year you'd appreciate how color
would resonate but unfortunately this is
the only image we have but at this time
a great deal of this kind of work these
exhibitions these big installations were
taking place at the tree and alley and
at other exhibition centers throughout
Italy remember that this is um the
architects at this time we're working
under a fascist regime it was the 1930s
there's a great desire to express
national identity this exhibition by
Albini with again Giovanni Romano was
the aeronautics exhibition it was
exhibited in 1934 at the same time that
Eduardo PepsiCo and Magellan easily
installed this exhibition that's called
the Hall of gold medal
I'm sorry for such a degenerated
photograph that's all we have but it's
very important because just two years
later Romano and eldini install this
exhibition clearly a tribute to PepsiCo
PepsiCo and albini had a relationship of
mutual respect and when pair circle
wrote about albini he said that Albini
was really the national face of
rationalism in Italy he gave just the
best expression to be understood among
other rationalist tendencies in Northern
Europe to define what was Italian about
this version of the work
this exhibition is called the antique
gold works show and it's again using the
glass of secret so that when it was
permeated by the company and recognized
for excellent use of the materials and
published in this April 1930 April 1937
Casabella journal that I found in the
studio album II was very interesting to
find out that across the page was an
image of a radio sitting up on laughs
legs designed by the artist
Enrico pallucci and there was even a
little mark made at the corner of the
page showing that Oh being a head
acknowledged that when he then produces
his blast radio he strips it Baer uses
the material in an even more abstract
way and floats the internal working of
the radio above the sound producing
circle to further destabilize the look
and you can imagine what it seemed like
to have a voice emerging floating into
the room from this strange object a
beanie was extremely playful in his use
of materials and this bookshelf is one
of the best examples of that in an era
of machine aesthetic Montford 802 40
called this a useless machine it had no
real capacity until it was loaded with
books because all of these glass
bookshelves are hanging in tension from
the compression columns the columns
these V columns are handcrafted wood
elements and um the project built in
1948 called vegan Orvieto is the Italian
name for
sailing vessel of sail sailboat
in 1941 when he produced this exhibition
the black and white show or the ship
yoni show as it's also known at the
biodome Museum in the napoleonic rooms
it drew significant attention it did
something else it took the paintings off
the wall and it floated them in the room
so the experience of seeing the work was
not the same sequential one painting
after another but you'd see them all
floating in the space and would see a
number of images at the same time it was
a radically different way to see art
that little column that got
reconstructed a number of ways will
appear in many many projects by Franklin
beanie and his partners in this case in
1954 in the Olivetti showroom in Paris
he shows that the system of installing
works well lit and so on is just as good
for selling typewriters as it is for
exhibiting works of art and in studio
albani today one can find myriad
examples of the different handcrafted
elements that were made for different
installations when Renzo Piano was
working in Rome to build the patio de la
musica the new auditorium of Rome and
they discovered an ancient city the
artifacts of the city get exhibited by
piano this way in that sight and in M
series of housing projects albini looks
for any way possible to make dance
housing more lyrical here you see this
external stairway that could also be
seen as an influence on piano when he
renovates the port harbor in the city of
genoa I won't spend a significant amount
of time on the housing designs by Franco
beanie but it's a very important part of
his early career throughout the 1930s he
working with Giancarlo pa'lante and
Renato pan Camus received nine
commissions and design a series of
housing complexes entire neighborhood
quarters throughout the city working for
the fascist public housing authority
four of these complexes are built and
this is one of them this project is
known as the Fabio field si quarter has
449 apartments in ten buildings five
people per apartment
means he's designing basically a city
for 2,000 people it was published in
Casa Bella as an oasis of order but fans
of neoreul of cinema will recognize from
Visconti's film Rocco and his brothers
that this site was used to portray an
inhuman environment where southern
Italian migrant laborers tried to settle
and tried to make homes in Milan the
exsistance minimum standard for housing
adopted from German housing of the
period was adopted by the Italian
authorities to try to produce the
necessary efficient and economical
housing and the Italians working in
Milan were certainly obliged to that
system but they tried their best to make
aesthetic environments including this
interior from fabulous field see with
drawings by studio Albini that were
exhibited at the tree not a and another
example of the change the versatility
the flexibility in albania's language
can be observed by and just one example
of the housing he produces in the
post-war period again the standards have
clearly changed but with the important
housing project the inna casa housing
the 14 years of producing public housing
after the war Albania was involved in a
number of them this one called the CH is
at a neighborhood outside of Milan shows
low-rise buildings two-story walk-ups
with a unit plan type that's quite
different changing the views and so on
so again housing is a body of work that
Alpena carries out throughout his career
but you're not likely to find be able to
identify the buildings by look alone
it's at this critical period before the
war and immediately afterward when an
important part of Albanese values about
architectures process of design gets
formed and it's largely because he's
working in mostly in interior design
interiors was the position he held when
he taught me jews epic simona in venice
between 1949 and 1964 and the quality of
interiors with transparencies with
reflective surfaces crea
rooms within rooms even using modest
furniture our characteristics that we
can find in these early apartment
building interiors that he did this one
for the Phe family very very simple but
he's always exploring ways to do things
in a unique way and the tree nalli of
Milan gave these architects a great
outlet for explorations of ideas for
experimentation in 1936 Albee knees
contribution to that year's tree and
alley was this little tiny project
called room for a man he plays with the
dialectic of the mind in the body a kind
of dualism where he locates all of the
components related to the body the upper
part of the slide in the back of the
series all of those things referring to
the mind come in the front and believe
it I do or the bookshelf is the one
thing that gets shifted off the
rationalist grid the glass bookshelves
are also the element that gets to rise
above the datum and become the tallest
element it's kind of totem within the
room but you see here the play of
materials the aesthetic nature of his
explorations four years later he takes
another has another opportunity to build
a Milanese tree and a lay installation
this one is called living room for a
villa and in this project instead he's
creating a polemic out of the duality of
inside and outside at this time Joe
Ponte had written a very important essay
trying to characterize and distinguish
the modern Mediterranean residents from
those modern homes of the Bauhaus north
of the Alps and his primary point was
Italians could live outside so in lovely
climate so we blend and blur interior
and exterior spaces and so Albania is
exploring this with his aviary and Birds
enclosed in the space his tree and
underground grass that's covered with a
glass surface and manipulating all of
these things in a kind of exploratory
and playful way but his first
opportunity to put into play the ideas
about the modern house was this building
for the lawyer Pastorini the building is
referred to as the Valletta testa Dini
on the edge of the city of new
it's a free-standing house and you can
see from the site plan but he crowds the
building on the corner right up to the
sidewalk so the building in fact the
dwelling is really a wall to the
landscape and that wall has to shifted
bars and as a good rationalist he uses
geometric principles and a simple
geometric palette to organize all of
these spaces where one long room is the
primary space of the house that then
gets subdivided on the main level and
the kind of geometric components are
easy to see quite evident this building
too was appreciated by Giuseppe Pagano
who publishes it in the same year in
Casa Bella magazine and with a beautiful
set of Hasselblad black-and-white
photographs depict this very iconic
modern modern building and even
publishes the construction cost for the
house in detail prizing it for being so
efficient so economical and so on and
like so many modern houses we see there
was color involved and in later years
when franca hell visited the building
she was surprised to see the use of
color and said that she believed that it
wasn't until she entered the studio that
Albini really became aware of an
infinitely used color the floors
terracotta the marble the wood and then
painted metal all characterized certain
qualities of this house this was 1939
one of his most notable interior
experiments was given to him as an
opportunity by designing the interior
apartment in the roof of one of the
museums that he works in in the optical
space for caffeine emission Otto katha
Dino was an important patron hired him
to design for museums ultimately in the
city of Genoa and commissioned him to
design her apartment which you see here
this very exotic kind of hanging cap
over a suspended hearth piece for
burning and a stone hearth that's meant
to look like it's floating in the space
and this apartment like a number of the
other pieces he's doing at this time
continue to play with ways of suspending
materials in space no apartment though
is more important than his own for the
experiments this his family apartment in
nineteen forty seems to use all of the
elements at once and set him up for a
number of the projects especially the
gallery installations that will follow
so you see the painting has left the
wall the wall can no longer reuse
because it's now covered with a shrimp a
scrim of veil that filters the light
into the room disguises the windows of
as framed openings you see the glass
radio that's now become a side table the
vignette Oh bookshelf acts as a room
divider
he loves horizontal surfaces that
reflect light Joe punky publishes this
building as well so all of this is
significant because it means Alby needs
work is being immediately disseminated
at at the time that he's working it's
available to many and it's really this
early that albini decides that the room
is the unit element of making modern
architecture he is committed to
designing from the inside out and
looking at the tension of the potential
relationships all of his novel and
innovations are meant to work together a
kind of composed unity within that
allows that room within a room to be
full of dynamic tension and set up
relationships of the space form surfaces
and so on and a number of ideas I think
can be kind of parsed out of that what
is it about the characteristic of his
rooms what are the kinds of things that
he continues to do in his work he finds
ways to divide the rooms up but maintain
views through the room so while the
artifact demands a lot of attention the
transparency is apparent and the
relationship of the the figure of the
shape of the floating element and the
surrounding the perimeter of the room
creates a strong center and edge tension
the attention to that figure also is a
important because he uses such lovely
material craft such care in crafting the
artifact these things have endured or
with us today but perhaps most important
in all of these experiments is the point
at which he uses the novel modern
element inside a historic environment so
that we begin to see this important
juxtaposition of new and old elements
that becomes an important part of his
legacy and many of the other architects
of that time period
so for albini this idea of the primal
room may not readily seem so significant
until one begins to think about what
others are doing at this time so during
the 30s and 40s we know very well the
beautiful experiments and houses of Mies
van der Rohe Gropius the Corbusier and
so on who are all designing modern
objects the buildings are exploded
houses or point line and plane there
artifices that are viewed and designed
from the outside in yet we know another
favorite modernist who eventually comes
to the same conclusion that in fact the
room is the primal element of modern
architecture but it's not until the 50s
after well after Kahn designs the Yale
art gallery his tour de force of
geometry in the open plan that he
decides in fact after the Trenton
bathhouses
famous for his use of served and
servants spaces that he'll no longer
rely on the open plan but use the the
defined room the room with proportions
the room was a contained space and the
geometries to go with that the original
photograph that I showed you by William
Penn of Albania was 1948 48 was a really
important time you know beanies life he
had lost many good friends during the
war he was now working more exclusively
on his own and he gets a very strange
Commission in the city of Chania on the
north he produces this youth hostel for
petrol vinyl an alpinist a skier and
this is a youth hostel doesn't look like
much else
beanies done but we've already
established that not many of those
buildings look alike the concept for
this building is the Byetta
or the traditional mountain village home
is raised up you see the typical
dwelling of wood and very steep roofs
and it's lifted up on these three-story
tapered columns or peel ot holding the
accommodation space above and other
social spaces dining and so on below now
this building got al being in a lot of
trouble with the sia architects you're
aware of the fact that the canonical
modern modernists who were very much
invested in a maintaining a strong
radical abstract international style
modernism throughout Europe was
beginning to have some doubts about the
Italians this is long before BBP ours
tour of Alaska building in Milan but it
certainly didn't look very modern to
most of the world but it o exam be on
the other hand defended this building as
a very good example of what he was
looking for an organic architecture and
it's not only because of the use of
materials but because there was a true
exploration in the design of the
building in the way it was crafted how
it was crafted the qualities of the
spaces and even in this dining space the
a perpetual example that we find
throughout his work is the clerestory
windows that creates a slice of glass
horizontally and makes the most of the
views in this case these mountain views
but also in 1949 albini gets his first
major museum commission from medina
machado and they're a couple of ways in
which it's been proposed that met Renato
learned about albini she very much
admired the show at the brietta with the
suspended artworks she was also there
was an employee in her public office
that was a brother of giovanni romano
with whom eldini commissioned but
however she came to know his work they
bonded immediately around a common need
which is that these dwelling museums
these these kind of dusty old dark
museums that housed very important works
of art in general simply had to be
modernized opened up lighted in a
different way
and she found in Albini the architect
with whom she could work
the Palazzo Bianco museum is published
in George Kidder Smith's book Italy
builds and this is a point at which a
book that circulated widely then brought
Albanese work to an international
audience see that kid or Smith opens
here saying that it might be said with
more than a grain of truth that Italians
have the finest art and the worst
museums in the world so he credits
Albini with changing that the building
had been bombed by the Allies so it was
virtually gone the palazzo building had
already been reconstructed before Albini
was commissioned he was invited to do
one installation initially with Mission
Otto before he was commissioned to
completely renovate the collection for
the building and essentially what albini
did was find ways to incorporate all of
the spaces in a way in which the
traditional spaces could still be
observed but now with his blast systems
closing the loggia and so on and
introduced the neutral white gallery
really for the first time in Italy by
doing so by inserting it within a
baroque Palazzo the quality of light
that he was able to work with was
beautiful of course it had to be
filtered to deal with the collection but
he and mention Otto began to think about
novel ways of exhibiting these works
taking historic works out of their heavy
frames exhibit exhibiting like you see
here in clusters working with
certain traditional qualities of the
space like the reflective glass floor
and in other cases choosing abstract
surfaces that worked best for the
materials and he did a number of things
that were controversial not appreciated
by curators including trying to create
this kind of easel exhibition by pinning
a rod in a medieval building fragment
they weren't very happy about that but
the most controversial was this piece
which did not last the beautiful 14th
century pizanno sculpture of margarita
de Brabant a was positioned on a piston
so that viewers in the museum could
actually operate this and put it in the
best light that certainly didn't last
however at this time Scott Penn Albini
were teaching together in Venice and
Scott have admired this project very
much she wrote Albania a letter and he
asked him about specifically about his
lighting system he also liked the vivant
a piece and so when he introduced a
museum in the Palazzo Abbot Ellis in
Palermo he positions
Eleonora de Toledo in this way another
bust of a noblewoman that became the
focal point of a beautiful room Albini
now is working with franca helg and
Albanian held received the Commission in
1952 to renovate another domestic
Palazzo across the street from the
Palazzo Bianco this one known as the
Palazzo turell's so it's a much longer
project it's a much more difficult more
complex project they stand up to yet
more local criticism for the work it
takes them 12 years to complete the
project
but many of the pieces that begin to get
developed serve in this case it's
worthwhile recognizing and that the city
of Genoa had us as important an impact
on Albini as he had on the city itself
the city has the densest intact medieval
fabric in in Europe which means streets
are so narrow you can touch buildings on
both sides very little light gets
through that dense fabric and so he had
to work with the light available to make
this building work again from the inside
out using the light the daylight there
and this Palazzo is unusual for another
reason it was commissioned by two
nobleman brothers in the 17th century
that had their duplexes one above the
other so you didn't have the traditional
single piano nobile a level you had two
and one brother stayed in the building
the other brother died before he was
able to complete the interior fresco
wing so you
parts of the building that look like
this parts that look like this and you
have this dichotomy of wonderful quality
of spaces but very difficult to exhibit
the work in those spaces that are highly
frescoed and decades of curators have
criticized much on auto and albini for
the way they handled the restoration of
that work but this stairway then was the
tour de force on Albanese part to create
a new public circulation system where
there was none there was no single
system to go vertically through the
building and this was his solution to
that problem the stair all hangs from
above so it's just delicately sitting on
the ground it's completely suspended
another device developed by Albion in
helg along with merchant auto for this
building was these pivots that would
allow a viewer of the works of art to
again position them in the light that
was most desirable well that didn't last
but again it's gotta appropriated the
idea that the abbot Ellis by hanging the
beautiful Anton LOD Mussina's and in in
Palermo these pivotal structures remain
so returning to the apartment that
albini design commissioned Otto and you
see her here in the figure on the far
side
Metron Otto herself had a beautiful art
collection and it must have been a
pleasure for him to install her work in
her own apartment as he designed this
optical apartment again
plunk T made it well-known by publishing
and describing this great work of art as
a work of architecture and when I began
my work in Genoa I was very disappointed
to find that it had been used as a
warehouse it was learning from the van
curator how much respect had been lost
for albini particular in this project
and I'm happy to say that after recent
restoration not only has the space been
returned to much more what it was like
when Metron Otto lived there but also
it's now part of the gallery sequence so
it's a public space that can be visited
in the building although her original
collection is no
exhibited there many of the works of
Albanians furniture are in place I
return now to the Treasury of son
Lorenzo this was met Renato's third
commission two Albanian hug and the two
enter the small four circles underground
one must first enter the duomo of the
city of genoa this 11th century basilica
and upon entering past the nave through
the sacristy descend underground and the
original project published in unesco x'
magazine called museums looked like this
the first plan had 5 cylinders later
we'll see it has 4 coincidentally in
this publication Louis Kahn's Yale art
galleries included in the same volume
now Albini source for the design of this
building was the treasure of Atreus at
Mycenae and we know this because Albini
took his students from Venice to see the
treasury and he sent a postcard back to
Merton Otto and in the postcard he says
you were right
so it had been obviously a part of a
dialogue that they'd had Albini then
from this important 13th century bc
project comes back with the idea of the
stacked stone the local stone that
creates a particularly sublime kind of
horizontality to this round room stacked
layers dark brooding underground but
it's the perfect environment for a crypt
full of gilded chalices and gem studded
robes these precious ancient religious
sacred artifacts that had been brought
back to the city of genoa during the
Crusades by William Oh embody itchy and
unfortunately this slide is washed out
due to the flash but you see the
promontory stone this stone is a local
Genoa stone there is no more of it it's
matte finish so it doesn't reflect light
it's kind of beautiful though you can
see people's hand marks
on the side of the doorway this is
attributed to the saint and her bone and
flesh can be seen inside this silver
piece and Albini never occupied the
center of a circle he built all of the
interior infrastructure and very
sophisticated and beautiful lighting
system to be able to appreciate these
precious works but he never occupies the
center so the final plan of this
building is in fact this one and this is
the plan that was published in
architectural form in 1957 and I'm quite
sure that this is the plan that Phillip
Johnson saw when he produced his
painting gallery in 1965 I doubt that
Johnson actually visited the Treasury
and if he did he wasn't particularly
influenced by the sublime and phenomenal
qualities of that space and I don't know
if anyone ever asked Philip Johnson with
40 acres why why all those beautiful
Follies in your landscape why put the
painting gallery underground but
nonetheless in conversation with Philip
Johnson especially and as he's
interviewed by Vincent Scully what would
you suspect he uses as his historic
reference for this project the treasury
of atreus at this time Albee knees
studio has grown now to include franca
Hogue as his partner she remains in the
studio through his death and continues
to run studio Albani for 12 years and
tell her own death this is a fun
photograph because when one sees it
zoomed out he's standing three stairs
lower because he was much taller than
she is photographer got them to appear
more egalitarian in staging the
photograph so franca Held's influence
can't be underestimated but neither can
it be easily assessed franca held wrote
a very important piece called the
testimony to Frank Roubini two years
after he died and she effectively
credits him for everything that they did
together there's another important woman
in Albie's career in
Mathilda Bafa I was directed to meet her
very early in my work Mathilda bhava as
a young student in Venice was a student
of Albanese and after a very difficult
competition he selected her to be his
teaching assistant and research
assistant at Venice he warned her that
it would be a very very difficult
position for a woman at that time in the
mid-50s
and the next day she got a call from
franca Helga saying he means that when
he says it's difficult but I encourage
you to take the job he's wonderful to
work for and she did and later she
became full professor at the Polytechnic
of Milan where she was then Albanese
colleague she's been a great help to me
in this work she provided me with the
book called the MFA the movimento police
to ddr cadet Duda is a collection of
talks by over a 16-year period from
forty-five to sixty one was put together
by Bafa and three others because at that
time the students in Milan had no place
to access a modern curriculum Milan at
that time was still taught by
classicists so Venice was the only real
Modern School in Italy the collection of
essays and talks reflects what they were
all talking about then and Albania was
one of the eleven architects that put
that group together and it was one of
the more important not necessarily one
of the more vociferous or common but he
spoke very clearly and intelligently
about what he believed was the
relationship between modernity and
tradition at that time so I am indebted
to to Bafa for her generosity and her
assistance in this work I'm gonna really
flyby to projects these are two office
buildings the importance is that they
are both begun in 1950 means before hell
gives in the studio and again they
illustrate my claim that he was not
bound at all to style but instead opini
was greatly influenced by the contexts
in which he's working still in Genoa we
see the building that's long been
referred to as the new municipal offices
it's now called only recently Palazzo
Albini
it's a u-shaped structure that sits
behind the baroque palazzo tortoise
the Town Hall of the city of Genoa the
town council chambers are located under
that egg-shaped roof and his interest in
light and views is apparent in choosing
this kind of U shaped diagram that does
not sit symmetrically behind the Palazzo
but he shifted he uses shading systems
to control the light but meanwhile in
the light Penance penetrates deeply into
this space that all offices have access
to daylight and views of the
Mediterranean so you see here the way
the building has been shifted but you
also notice something else that it's the
one building that looks like no other
buildings in the context so where for
the four centuries after the Renaissance
that Italians built up the hillside of
Genoa they built largely cubic kind of
volumetric boxes and he chooses to build
a 10-story Terrace that ships back moves
back to arrive at this coastal atone
neighborhood above in a distinctly
different diagram it also includes a
pedestrian promenade that cuts right
through the space so one can assault the
hill as a pedestrian and arrive to a
completely different neighborhood from
the public central hall the monumental
courtyard of the Town Hall Palazzo and
right up the side of the hill under the
public elevator to arrive and have a
beautiful view back over the slate
rooftops of the city of Genoa in the
Mediterranean below it's the first
example that I know of of a green roof
anywhere and he creates these
contemplative Gardens unaccessible
at the very same time in the city of
padma he designs another insurance
company headquarters here we see another
example of the palazzo building lifted
up a facade building in a way that the
offices in Genoa have no interest in
being a facade certainly not competing
with the facade of the Baroque Palace
but this facade plays some very
interesting compositional games with the
use of the grid and the layers of that
grid you can read I think in this
photograph that the columns the plasters
that make up the vertical elements of
the
did taper back they get thinner as they
go up as they meet that overriding
cornice you can understand too that
that's Palazzo type building has been
lifted up so it's it's rising above on
pilaster z-- and it's easy to see then
that the that concrete frame is not
structural it's completely ornamental
the structure of the building is shown
here and they don't line up so he's
completely interested in an expression
of a facade a plaid lattice that allows
him to play shifty games this building
by fujian paulinho Torino seems to be at
least influenced by this game of
shifting the locating the concrete
plaster right through what should be
rectangular or orderly frame of a window
so we've seen that the structural
exoskeleton sometimes is and sometimes
isn't sometimes it's a faux structure
but with though going to shantae store
obviously it's fulfilling its job of
being an extra structure of a complete
structure for that Palazzo building in
this building has has worn fairly well
here when it's first built surrounded by
lots of little Cinquecento cars and
today in a renovated state it's it plays
a pretty significant role in that city
and again I think one can recognize a
certain similarity to the use of the
palazzo typology the structural
exoskeleton with infill panels even to
the uncanny similarity of the six glass
windows creating a monumental
composition of symmetry on one side so
I'll leave it for you for a moment to
speculate what the potential
relationship between Louis Kannan and
Franco beanie may have been while I go
on to show just the last two museums of
Albanese career in the late 60s we're
already getting to a point at which
Italians are no longer convinced that
modern interventions into the historic
fabric are viable are desirable they
and after these two buildings by Albini
and the works of such as castle vecchio
and Scapa and BBP are at the sorts of
castle in milan we see no more of that
kind of risky but bold intervention in
the historic fabric in the city of genoa
again at the san agustin o museum
complex we find the last commission of
Katrina mission Otto for suyog franca
and Franco and just about the same time
in the city of Padua the Civic museum
complex asks for a catalyst similar kind
of project because in both cases we have
basilica's and double Kleiss turd
infrastructure that were bombed by the
Allies nearly destroyed and require an
intervention that makes critical
decisions about what part of the
historic fabric should be restored what
part should be replaced and what balance
should occur between them here in Genoa
at the san agustin o hill top we see the
fabric of the old church where this
delightful little 13th century
triangular courtyard is largely damaged
but it's completely restored in the
project meanwhile the rectangular
cloister next to it had been completely
demolished now this church complex is
one that had been deconsecrated already
for many centuries Napoleon had stashed
his horses and troops there and so on so
it had not served as a religious site
for a long time but one of the
components of the albini project was to
continue the pedestrian promenade right
through the triangular courtyard to make
a breakthrough what you saw was a very
long open block that Networking the city
shows how much time and attention albini
paid to the city of narrow passageways
and allowed for that kind of system the
we've seen projects in which Albania was
very much focused on a facade
architecture and in this case we find
that his expression of us facade is much
simpler much more subtle less powerfully
expressive or at least in company
or in evidence with the surrounding area
but certainly a sophisticated
development of this the infrastructure
of the exoskeletal steel structure and
infill panels so on the piazza
siddhasana we see the facade of the
building
marrying continuing the facade of the
others and a really understated entryway
into the museum we again a look at what
the city of genoa offers up as
pedestrian passage ways these stepped
ramps are characteristic of this very
hilly city and he appropriates that
directly brings a stepped ramp in to the
building as a way of sliding up through
the museum and the collection in this
museum is largely remnants of medieval
architecture so a lot of it is stone and
can take bright sunlight so that loads
of space that exterior cloister is the
source of views and light and in looking
at the interior infrastructure again
like architects of his period
albini very much designed every detail
when I showed these sketches to a
collaborator Vittorio pnina he said that
those were actually ideas of franca
Held's she designed that particular
detail but one of the things that became
apparent to me in this project is it's a
unique opportunity to see what Albini
does in Section when dealing with such a
complicated site he really had three
distinctly different ideas about modern
glass three different ideas about
transparency and used all three of them
stacked in section here the top level
around that central cloister space he
extends the six-foot deep steel beam so
that he needs no corner column he takes
the corner column away altogether and we
know from studies the Renaissance the
problem at the corner column perpetually
created here he just removes it
meanwhile at the main level of the
galleries we find this relatively
traditional cloister Center but he
rebuilt that that was not a historian
actual his
moisture he rebuilt it columns with
entasis
arches capitals and so on and and was
significantly criticized for that act
but what I see when I look at that is a
different kind of solution to a problem
in he's housing this faux artifact in a
glass box
he's got edges to that box he details
the glass box just like he does with all
of the other glass boxes for his
installations of artifacts so now he's
using the glass to hold another object
and finally at the lowest level of the
building we see a submerged glass box a
kind of inside-out glass house that
brings light deep into the space and so
each of the three of these components
use them the medium to do different
things for the building and with a very
similar problem to solve about the same
time in the city of Padua we find a
complex that had also lost completely
one of its cloisters from the church and
this time it's the minor cloister and
this time instead of rebuilding the
space he allows it to be very simple
using a again his steel structure in a
pattern in which the paired columns
create ornament and make the give this
kind of articulation of very clearly
modern elements against the brick wall
of the old cathedral and in using the
centered columns again he removes the
corner so you get a very different
expression of weight of gravity
something very heavy and very dark a
long way from the lyrical light
modernity of his early rationalist days
there's another portion of this project
that was not completed much of Albanese
work here was not finished by him but
this Pina kotake project was completely
detailed all the drawings were done was
ready to go and they begin to get cold
feet about including modern
interventions with historic fabric so
this five-day gallery is never completed
and yet and we see long narrow spaces
beautifully proportioned in section with
daylight entered in along the spine
light that bounces off the reflecting
panel that also holds the artificial
light systems and no surprise we can
find the great similarity once again to
the work of Luke on so here we are what
have you decided what is their
relationship it's been a conundrum for
me throughout this work because I think
it's not so difficult to understand how
Johnson was influenced by Albini or how
Lina Bo Bardi or even Kalos Scot but
engaged in a dialogue they work together
they shared a lot but between Kahn's new
monumentality and al beanies magical
abstraction we find similar responses to
a post ideological modernism both
architects are very active during a
period of late modders with clearly
criticisms of the problems of the
ubiquity of the one-size-fits-all
international style has not missed them
land speculation mass marketing mass
consumption all of these things were
changing completely the environments in
which they worked and both of them
taught while they practiced they were
involved in the discussions of their
time they showed a great deal of
reverence for human culture and not an
easier nostalgic idea of tradition but a
tradition that was very carefully
defined and critically accept critically
assess but above all was constantly
changing they introduced a new reverence
for the site the context the city the
human experience and the integrity of
materials always with innovation where
tradition and modernity were no longer
perceived in opposition both architects
albeit from different cultures came to
the same conclusion of a situated
modernism
I also looked for all the potential
times they were in the same room
together Khan of course had a Prix de
Rome Albanese works at Siam were
published specifically after the
bridgewater meetings in 56 Khan
presented the Richards Medical Center at
Siam in 1959 and albini was there Albini
spoke at Princeton in the early 60s
we know he spoke English and of course
under Samanas leadership at the U of in
Venice all the great Modern architects
passed through but the only time I could
find convincingly that they were
actually together was in Massachusetts
in 1964 when Bobby and Jackie Kennedy
invited nine internationally renowned
architects to consult on the development
of the Kahn of the Kennedy Library the
competition or the Commission that later
went to I am Pei so here over Bobby
Kennedy's shoulder we see a smiling
Frankel Albini
and on the other corner of the image we
see a surreptitious leucon peeking out
of squinty eyes and they're right in the
middle is a big old happy Mies van der
Rohe at Jackie O yeah and I'm gonna
conclude now it's just a brief final
story in the years of working on albini
we hosted an exhibition of his work and
with that we held a symposium and we
asked the question about of his
relationship between modernity and
tradition and that of other scholars
from comparative studies and literature
and Fine Arts and Marco albini joined us
at that meeting mark well Deanie was
very interested in this what my students
chose to do was to build a mock-up of
that beautiful vignette or bookshelf we
looked all over Milan couldn't find it
ask Marco Marco said yeah it's broken
sin my mom's closet don't know how to
put it back together again there was
only one she said okay we'll give it a
try
so we refabricated our own mock-up of
the vignette Oh bookshelf he was
convinced although we missed the scale
by about nine-tenths okay still supports
books
and he went back to the casino company
he said hey casino
don't you think you can make one those
kids at Ohio State can do it can't you
do it sure
so for the wonderful zero-gravity
retrospective that Renzo Piano installed
in the turn Ollie and Milan 2006 Cocina
refabricated the narrow but of course
they're not going to do it just once now
you can have one too okay
for only twenty three thousand uro
vignette ou can be yours and I'm telling
you I'm not selling mine on eBay thank
you for your attention and I'd be happy
to address questions
thank you for comprehensive presentation
of an organizer I'm sure that most of us
really don't know or maybe thought we
knew but now know far better very
interesting work and interestingly
presented I'm sure there might be some
questions or comments about the work or
they are talk please
Daniel here I hear wait a minute wait
for the mic we don't want to lose a
moment of your voices so it's for the
recordings recording Philip Johnson it
seems returned again to albini
in the pre-columbian museum and
Dumbarton Oaks which was a pod like
constant which was extruded upwards it
was as if the treasury of atreus and
that earlier yet none of the subtlety of
the geometrically related circles right
those are all the same dimension circles
you know surrounding right and you
mentioned Lina Bo Bardi and the mosque
and how the radical gesture which she
thought was Democratic of taking the
paintings away from the aristocratic
surfaces of the Palazzo or Museum and
then putting them on those support
systems that's very much on beany
inspiration they both worked for Jo
Ponte right correct
and then Massimo scolari told me the
davenport professor here Danielle I read
your piece on Albania and therefore you
know who I really am
tradition and modernity but I refuse to
build I think so Scolari does he credit
albini and you don't yes who says that
albini was the most important figure for
him
in 1966 before he met Rogers actually
was a 64 that he took Oh be nice course
66 Rogers and then Rossi okay so scolari
really sees himself as a child about
being has he written about that no you
need to write that I did okay yeah
Daniel excuse me questions not
questions and without flies and the boys
no I had not okay we can discuss this
over a drink Dancy KB I am NOT an
architecture sophisticated so this may
not be an interesting question at all
but you made two statements that I
wonder if if they're correlated one is
the room as his basic unit of
architecture and the other no set style
and so I'm wondering if you start with a
room as the unit does that mean that
that leaves all the other options open
for the larger for the building for the
object okay so your question is if
you're starting from the room by
definition are you going to always not
get to the same point thank you yes
possibly but I think you know most
architects care deeply and think greatly
about what their buildings look like on
the outside and inevitably as they're
developing ideas there's a certain
repetition or occurrence or desire to
develop an idea and we saw that also
with albini there were some buildings
that absolutely were facade buildings
and so he was working with excuse me
with systems on the outside clearly but
I think that what's great about all of
the buildings that I've experienced is
that the rooms are compelling they're
compelling for daylight they're
compelling for the integrity of the
materials for the proportions of the
rooms the sequencing of the rooms and
because of the nature of this kind of
modern architecture there's a continuity
between inside and outside so when you
saw that facade of the san agustin o
museum and these big steel frames around
windows and some big windows those
windows are at the end of the spaces
around the lodges where the narrow
windows are not so there's a correlation
between what you end up reading on the
exterior and what's happening inside the
building and my argument would be that
he's driven by the body of ideas that
grow from the inside out so that facade
is a result of that pattern of interior
spatial arrangement does that make sense
if he's starting with the room does that
lead to a greater variety of
as the end result I guess the reason
that's hard to say absolutely is because
every project has a different scale of
room if its domestic if its museum or
gallery scale and what I would argue is
sophisticated and important about Albini
is the care he takes to satisfy the
clients program so in other words for
him he said no longer works of art they
just need to be exhibited properly you
know he's very dedicated to the solving
of the problem before his problem which
is to express himself and so those are
some of the kinds of things that I think
inherently lead to an architecture of
greater integrity of greater ingenuity
or greater beauty and one component of
that is that he's designing so many
rooms early in his career that by the
time he gets to these larger urban
projects or more monumental scale
endeavors he has he can't help himself
but to work at the scale of a gallery
where the room or the space or the
courtyard and then ultimately resolve
the problem on next year thank you yes
question there's some more questions
please yes you commented earlier that
like the lack of translation into other
languages besides Italian and sort of
lack of primary materials as reasons why
more people don't know a lot about
Albini but what did you find was the
primary reason why he doesn't have a
higher profile so he built a lot of work
and I showed you the greatest hits in my
opinion there are some buildings that
maybe arguably are not this quality he
built some large-scale office buildings
he builds some chunks of cities that are
beyond scale and there are those
collaborators of albini in the past or
others who have said you know that
wasn't really albini that was those
other guys he worked with because there
is a high degree of respect for albini
himself he was a very taciturn guy in
the 50s when search became the Dean of
architecture at Harvard that
was first offered to rogers who turned
it down but my thinking is that if
Rogers had taken the job at that time he
would have brought all of his Italian
buddies and that albini would have had
much more exposure in the u.s. Albanian
built in Sao Paulo brought by the Babar
Dee's he built in Stockholm but again so
much of his important work
were these ephemeral installations
they're photographed but they've gone
away but beyond that I guess I would ask
you
having seen the work is it surprising to
you that they aren't better known or is
it seem sort of run-of-the-mill or
ordinary or too few to be important or
too insignificant because they're too
different from one another
maybe it's just harder to make a larger
journalistic sort of byline or like
title for his work in the way that it is
for you know con with you know modern
monumental ISM or something like that
Eenie didn't work very hard to sell
himself way back thank you you talked
about postal ideological of modernism
could you say any more about his
tendency towards a machine aesthetic
that was actually made by hand yes so
the furniture makers with whom Albini
worked love to talk about him there's a
guy named Poggi and another name Bona
chena the early furniture that he did
some of this stuff out of red tan and so
on they speak about Albini as a great
designer and architect because he worked
closely with them he was very interested
in the craft in the detail and
consequently sometime later the
furniture designer of equal majesty said
about albini he was born too soon by
which he means Albini didn't make it in
mass production like all the rest of the
guys did he was really invested in
making the perfect object but didn't
particularly care if it was
mass-produced or not the artifact that
you see that is this column that keeps
recurring it's different every time
depending upon the need and the
installation sometimes out of steel most
often out of wood but he keeps going
back to that
problem in refining it in very fine
detail time-consuming so I think in that
sense his interest in fabrication shows
in the work immediately and on site it
doesn't necessarily publish that well it
doesn't translate that well it doesn't
export that well but it's the kind of
architect he was it was what he was
dedicated to in his practice early on in
during this important period of
rationalism we know about those guys
that wrote the treatises and talked
about topologies and talked about the
new spirit of the time and that became a
kind of manifesto that was shared by
other young rationalist architects in
Italy albini was part of that but he
their copies of his versions of the
futurist manifesto and Bo chonies book
on futurist architecture with lots of
margin notes of him saying things like
balderdash this is kind of crazy you
know who needs this stuff because he was
not inherently inclined to speak
theoretically or to create a theoretical
argument or to sell an argument he made
stuff and he made stuff consistently and
well long enough that ultimately I think
we can look at it and see these
important continuities or things that he
achieved but not because he set out to
write a manifesto does that make sense
do I answer your question not so much
we're buying second Susie from what what
we've observed of albini and you talked
about tension
he worked best I don't think it's
because he didn't have good marketing
people his whole idea was about a
secondary move and given the context of
what we he had whether it was a room or
or like the Bianco young he was kind of
like a spider can I say that where you
make a web and you can't make that whip
unless there's something somewhere so
it's a secondary move and he's not a
fundamental macho kind of guy like Louis
Khan you know and I'm the structure I'm
the building yeah but he also a the
whole idea of in fact his buildings the
the building itself is quite what is it
fluid but he was like us he was very
good when he could insert as a secondary
secondary move what can I say you didn't
show something because probably you
didn't want to get bombed at for being
politically incorrect but you know he
did weird things but the designs he did
were but if you really think about it I
used to think he was like an Italian
macho you know that yeah he used to take
pictures of himself and with like Pilate
you know he would he would for ya he was
almost poor no no no this is very
important he designed brassieres and and
what is it no no your women no no it's
not not albini
you're thinking of Colorado man you know
oh I'm getting Italians mixed up
but the brassiere I'm going to say it's
about defying gravity and so it's do I
have to give my lecture okay I think
we're gonna quit on that except that I
wouldn't like to make one slight
observation that first of all I think
that was Paul Rudolph's face in that
Kennedy picture just half way in and a
half out he was one of the architects
considered for the library yes indeed
and he made the final cut of four yeah
but but I think we're all finished early
work like the exhibition see that and
you have to look and see if he was at
that meeting it's the crew cut but but I
just wanted to make one sort of artists
are artists Oracle observation I think
Rudolph was very influenced by Albini in
its early career in the installations
like the family of man and the good
design installations of the MoMA and the
the place in Chicago in the Canada at
the Kennedys actually on the design
center so I think
albini was perceived as a kind of
interior and exhibition architect and
the arena Shantay was well received but
it was a surprise
interesting that's my bit older and so
that's the way I thought but I think
it's time to thank you for incredibly
good